Hello?
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me good?
Oh my god
Am I live?
Am I live on the wrong thing?
Why is Chad not moving?
Well, oh wait
Are we good?
She live
Why does it seem like the
Oh shit, I have you me plus concert open twice. I
Didn't poop I didn't do it. I couldn't do it. I didn't have I didn't have enough time. I didn't do it
Okay, strongy and she be already in VC. I don't know if I should join them or not
No, I feel kind of shy
Um, okay, it says ultra-lily and see that's good. I don't have the
Let me see I'm not sure if I have the
Discord reactive images thing. Oh here it is
Should I should I join them?
I have to set it up a little bit discord call I have to like add everything
Yeah, of course join them. Okay
Hopefully they're not talking about anything bad
Yeah
At strongy
She be
Um
Joining your call well live. I don't know if they're alive yet. So I
Just want them to know that I'm joining
Hopefully they saw that I mean they're in the live VC. So like if they didn't see that then
Don't talk about silly stuff while in the live VC. I'm excited too. I'm super super excited. I I'm a big mimosa fan
I
I'm not only here for them for my most of course. I love the other girls too, but I'm a big mimosa fan
And we had to I like Rhea
Okay, I'm gonna join they better not do some weird stuff like I did with the
Stranny here it comes wait, let me turn my sound up the sound should be okay
Hello
I'm what yeah, I was what
I
Said hi in me
Sighted voice because you were talking to your cat because I know you go light voice when you're happy. Yeah
Oh my god. Oh, what's shit mama? I can't even tell my daughter's heart
Ray hello in me
What I was trying to say is that I accidentally well
I wasn't me here. Um, and I made she be cry because she got a lot of gifted memberships and oh, yeah
I don't let's not talk about that
It was adorable
It was embarrassing I was
Definitely embarrassed. No, it's cute. Why are you embarrassed? It's good. You deserve them. I just it's it's I hate crying on stream
And I cry a lot. I'm such a cry like oh god everyone knows I'm a terrible mother
And told you that I'm live
I
Literally added you in general chance that I'm joining
Everyone's live I'm considering everyone live from now on no more veal or leaks and say this chat. That's why I was participating in
I mean you're muted at the start for a little bit. So no one heard you being no one heard you confusing me for she be
Now they know
I
May have confused my daughters appear because I'm just so
Daft ray I should actually probably start my stream too. Well, we're on it probably also do the same
Yeah, it's starting the concert starting. Come on guys. I know I'm not I'm trying to pop the Fuji tech
I'm trying. Oh, I've not even got Fuji tech. I'm gonna pop it
There you go, I'll put you right under I
Have a whole two minutes to figure out if I have Fuji tech or not
I'm pretty sure I called it me and the boys for the
The name of the source whenever we have our little watch
I
People are shitting on me for a light mode light mode you see how do I turn light mode? How do I turn out dark theme?
What oh
You're we kneecaps. Oh, you've got we band-aid on yeah
Could you put so much effort into your streams and I'm like, right? I'm just walking up five minutes ago
Let's go
I'm like, oh, I
Had time I had I had time to least so I did it
Yes, for those of you listening in you may plus were caned enough to give us permission and we're allowed to all talk to one another and but
You what?
We're not literally the audio
Um, but we're allowed to talk with one another and take notes and
Goes super amazing
Hi everyone
You excited, oh it's starting. Oh, no, it's not starting
I'm sorry, I thought it was starting
I
Excited you have a hearty gulp so high
I think
Mercy's about to join us now AC is the only one that was unavailable for this due to tame zones AC is currently sleeping right now
Fortunate taming for the darling, but please
Please don't count AC out yet
It's weird being invoiced at and not being allowed to spill all the secrets
So excited they just pause it says three
Okay
Technical difficulties, it's fine lives, it's fine
They're so cute, I can't
Right, I'm gonna
I've not got desktop audio and they're split so I can't hear the stream and you guys can
How did you guys split the audio I've got you guys captured via desktop
Oh, you have to you have to make um, what's it called a
Split yeah, you guys split and OBS you can do it. Yeah, that's what I did
I'm using I have two tip I have my headset and my I am's right now. I
Don't know hi here
I've bowls this watch along up. That's all I can say so far
I'll meet it once the finish their intro
Hello
Gushy
Oh, I'm like I got two things she can go show on right here
No, I reason says it's very sweet to help with a watch along another helping
Thank you for the gift the 20 gifted eternity. Oh my god. Oh
That's so kind of you. Oh my god. Thank you so much. Holy shit. Oh my god
Yeah, dude, my most is so talented she is
Actually got them lungs on her just Hayden. You wouldn't realize don't be fooled by the outfit. There's lungs under those
Oh
Her model so bouncy it is
I
Love the way eyelashes, I know it's not I know it's not beach of a racestream, but
I know I was like strawberries. I want to eat them
The flowers in her ears. I just let's
So nice
The breadsticks and chat. Oh
I like her custom mic
I didn't even notice that. Oh, you're really cool
God, I was talking about customized assets today and I was like I never got girls anything. That's okay. I
Was just like that was so it sounds terrible. I was like if I'm not going to use it. I'm not giving it to them
I've showed my end in screen for like the first time and literally since debut I showed my end in screen and everyone was laughing
Why do you hate the ending screen so much and I I don't
I don't like heart streams. I literally if you open up one of my vods, I'm just like
I don't know. I literally spent so much money on it
I'm just never use the thing. I've never even seen the stingers. I never even use stingers on debut. That's so much
Go this is fantastic, what this is beyond my expectations
Most is amazing. She's like an amazing amazing singer
Multi multi multi talented
extremely things streams
Uh
Freaking makes all her own charts as well
thumbnails
You name it. She does it. She does them all you didn't know she sings
Well, I'm supposed to keep up with everyone's talents in the Vtuber roster that I'm not aware of that's what I thought
You're not constantly stalking the most his channel with me
Well, I'm supposed to know absolutely everything about every other Vtuber of
Uh, it's been kind enough to interact with me. That's right. You're done for a reason bend over
Prepare yourself
Hello everybody. Hi, Haru. Something is in my eye
Well, we have a peak three phones
Sorry, I'm slurping the tea if anyone can hear that. No, I don't
Oh
Oh my god duets
Oh my god, how long is this concert that is like some built and in preparation
I'm like generally so impressed with the most his voice and burrows me too. I wish I could speak japanese
Imagine us up there
Let's forget singing in english. I can even imagine singing in a different language. Exactly
I
Think we got to get some japanese speakers for gen 2 mama. Oh, we're being influenced live. You heard it here folks
And I swear I saw what you quote you tweeted she be don't think I didn't see it
She went on twitter and she quote tweeted a slain girl. Oh, don't look at me
I'm not doing nothing
I freaking saw it
She didn't look slowly just putting it into your mind
I will get you a halloween variation outfit. You is a slain girl
Yeah, all y'all yours. I'm not having a
slain girl. It's all yours. You can be
Yeah, I can be the slain girl
Yes
All right, I'll settle I'll settle for that. I'm the slain girl who defeated the slain allegations
I'm so I'm I'm trying not to scream. I'm trying to focus on the
The thing because I'm about to be a jigglin on screen. I don't know if what you guys are looking at, but things are jiggling me
Two things are jiggling
Slime bunny girl like from queen's blade precisely
What cotton foam family member is going to be the slime girl. Um, how does it think about that?
Sublime
Shabash the slime
Oh my god, I adore her a little freaking
Put her little pony tails bob
Are we yearly?
Yearly fish ribbons as well like the translucent
Such a good thing
Unfortunately, it's my turn to sing. Hold on. Let me get my pen lights out
No
No, I'm on her should we get eye trackers out of that. I'll give every girl an eye tracker and we'll watch the most devious link
Videos and stuff and we'll see who's got like 93 pervert rate
This anime is lead
Oh
You enjoying a zero
Zero
Hello
Sorry, I died welcome back shibi. Thank you zero. Are you wanting to get off on stage?
Oh
I'm asking is there if she wants to go up on stage because she's watching this
I think her makes fucking dying
Yeah, we can't really hear you
Azura, are you alive?
Uh, she's muted again. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. I'll take that. She's so excited. She's so so excited to get up on
She just ran away. She's like
At the thought at the concept
Let me get let me get two pen lights out. I don't have different colors. I only have blue
I have so many questions for them that how long this took this is insane. I know
They should just like take the
The soundtracks here and just post them as song covers too
Honestly, that's a smart idea. I think they should I think they will
You think they will I hope so because it's really good. They shouldn't just leave it here on the stream
Like I want to I want full song covers
Let us hear your lungs this tiny jellyfish got lungs on our two goddamn
Azura is taking away my pen lights
Azura knows the words
Is Azura singing along to it? I think that's why she's muted
Damn
Azura don't be in the weave allegations. Oh
Oh
This concert is epic. Literally. I had no idea what to expect. I've never actually sat through a concert before
Uncle uncle give us another me. I don't know. I disagree. He's dying for me. It's hard to know
I'm just like so surprised like the stage like all the assets
Light show
It's really pretty mera is so cute. She is
Wait her little tentacles bounce is is there it is there is me at the audio, right? Or she's gonna get coffee, right?
I mean
I mean I'm not to play the audio of the stream
on stream
Question those pen lights are being held up by my arms
Oh, this goes hard
Got a different vibe
If I'm he started singing in Japanese I would have absolutely lost my mind
Wait is she about to
I think this is an English cover
If you guys had to sing a song for a concert, what would you say that's my question for you? I would rap something ridiculous
ABC's
I'm gonna sing five bars five seconds stop
I was pissing myself out of that climb
In the bed
I straight a fish. Yeah, I probably do American idiot possibly I like green day
Oh
Okay, I mean go off hit him hit him hit him hit him. Hey, hey, don't hurt him now
Kill them
Slay slay your enemy. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Don't
Whoa, that's so cool. Oh no, she's high
They just set the ambience
Feel that music feel them tunes
Mm-hmm
Wow
I saw it so I saw it execute me. I me
I don't know if you guys have ever played Alice madness returns
But wins the vibe when you get low health you interstate of them hysteria
And you unlock a different version like to your look and this
I me is like completely making me want to play Alice madness returns right now
That's a great game. I've heard of that game. I want to play it too
Oh, I recommend I meet darkness way. Yeah. I meet darkness dementia way just like my immortal
I love her mic too. All the song choices are really good too. They're all really catchy
Vibe in
Oh
Shit execution
Read down two more to go add them to the rasta
Ah
Three what they're all singing together
Are there songs that support this?
Oh wait
This is crazy. It's not just like one solo song or duets
Oh
Let's go
Oh my gosh
Okay
I'm muting and deafening right now so the other girls don't hear me
They're all so fucking good at singing it makes me want to jump off a building
Oh, I could only dream of being this good. Holy shit. Okay back to the girls
I
Love the mirror bounces her little your little tentacle pony tail
That must have taken so much work
I have so many questions for them after this like holy crap strawny. I'm sorry. I'm not singing in japanese
No, I'm not gonna ask you to holy crap. I would never ask you to sing in another language
Japanese fans would hate me because I would just butcher everything
Because I would not be able this is so beautiful and amazing to me. Should be my sorry
But
Yeah, yeah back again, I'll do I'll do Megan the stallion
That new one from Megan the stallion was yeah, I forgot the name of the faking song. I already forgot the name of the song too
I was like this morning
It took time up
I need some japan anglish songs to sing
I will sing that version some of the uptiles on it that aren't real words
I
She gives me cute aggression
I have seen the japanese version of dojica say so it is very good. It's very cute
That's it. I'm making the scottish version and getting a million views. You should you should
In the moment. I want to say
I've got shivers her voice is so clear
Oh
I'm literally getting shivers from her singing
You know, if you guys ever want to do song collapse I can set up one of the v-tubers for you
And
You want to sing magnet with me what's magnet vocaloid magnet
Oh, I don't know what that is even magnet
Oh, that's really weird. Oh my god. Am I aging myself right now? No, no, no
Wait, let me look it up. Maybe I'm just forgetting the name
Forbidden lovers
I've never heard this one. No
You've never heard magnet. No
Oh
Okay, strani, do you want to do magnet with me?
You're asking the wrong one
You were singing a
Um edge sheeran's thing of the whole bit. Yeah, I want to do that
My voice is so broken. You have no idea how hard it was to get mixers. We'll do a recorded concert
I'm just
You did not even sound like that come off it come off it now
There you use these these terminologies against me. I was there
I'm hanging out with you too much. That's why
Honestly, I'd be very interested to see how you're if you're a scottish accent would develop
Because she had never done it around me before until debut and then and then we did the
debut mock and she goes
I was I was uh
Holding my inner scots since I'm scottish myself
Yeah on my mom's side on my mom's side. Oh, you're mohan. I'll probably can or then
I didn't yeah, my great-grandmother immigrated from scotland. I didn't even know that
So cool. I'm here for it
Oh, she got her love eyes on she got her love eyes on
Oh
Hell yeah, go a little joke. Go a little joke. Go a little joke. Go I joked
The song is really good
Is this where I saved it in me that her song's being mixed right now. Oh, it's that's fortnite battle pass like
You're doing fortnite battle pass
I'm gonna let you talk about let it tell them what the plan was go ahead
So I really like emmy's voice and I wanted her to make a meme song cover
And the one song I really wanted her to cover is this song that's fortnite
I
Got her to battle go viral. I'll tell you that right now. This is my prediction
Live while she was away on holiday, but unfortunately we were having a lot of delay issues just everywhere
I mean just um, but she drew her own artwork for I'm getting it animated
And then it's been turned into a little cute video, but it's less than a minute long
So I'm gonna get it
We stan vocaloid shadow wizard money gang
Oh my god, rain's voice is so mummy
I love that rain has like a slight valley accent does she yeah, I didn't notice
Hmm
It's very very slight if it's her model so well though
Bibby's were jumping sorry I'm a child. I'm an absolute child forgive me forgive me
Veeler fortnite skins, absolutely
Could you imagine it was a freaking doing like cash money flow emo on someone after you killed him and it's just emmy's
And
She's in her jays like dancing over the parts of someone. He got first place. Oh my god
Oh, I would do an uh rata shigako song
I really like tokyo calling because it's about um
I thought you were going to say tokyo drift
No, no, no, it's called tokyo calling and it's about how
dystopian your life can become if you don't kind of find the meaning of it or that's what I took away from it and it's like
One of the lines that really resonates me is like the girl. They're singing magnet
Are they shut up?
I'm gonna lose it. I guess I'll hear magnet for the first time. Oh my god. I'm literally gonna cry
Is my this is one of my favorite vocal aid songs. Oh shit. Okay. Oh my god, actually
I'm geeking out. I'm geeking
Riefland's almost I was actually had sumiku was my uh entrance into the anime world to say the things I said what I said
Oh, are they gonna do the japanese or the english version? That's my question
The world oh, they're doing the japanese
Oh
Creaming your jarts they were creamed long ago. Thank you reya's voice
I love reya's singing voice. Oh my god, she sounds so like
It's a little bit more mature. It's so clear. I think almost ethereal. You know, yeah
Absolutely every time she opens she sings it gives me servers
I
Oh takes me back
I'm so happy right now
Me too. I like rain's mic mom. Can we get mics?
Okay, you make actually
This is insane or knowledge you guys aren't supposed to know this but
You can't keep a secret for the life of you. I swear to god
I'll say oh everyone else can know that's listening into a how many meeting with the girls in august and they can
Have we are going to discuss alternative outfits?
Well, I already know i'm getting slime
Well, that's for halloween, but like
For halloween. Oh shit. I'm under wait. Oh god, right?
You just said it was gonna be for halloween. She forgot what she said
If we're doing halloween costumes, i'm gonna need to
Fill some string
If you guys want halloween costumes
You must tell me in the meeting because I want to be a slime girl halloween
I want a halloween costume
I don't know what i'm gonna do for my alternate outfit
I saw you do that a
I think I'm gonna save the gyaru idea for
2.0
please
Remember when if you guys would like to sign on for the next year
We also offer a free alternative outfit um on the house
So if you have one idea you like, but it's not what you go for we can probably cover it later
Thanks, droney
Again insider knowledge
If you uh work under viola and sign on for the next year your split goes up on further 5% in your favor
All right, i'm just pulling them strings
My ever self-sacrificing mother
She's chilling
Like
No, what do you mean? He's on you don't like the way that you
Make you careful watching a concert
Oh strongy
Make sure it's so excited. That's why
Brov I literally leak everything. I like all of this place
um
As people know because ac is going to be in the meeting about all of this unfoldings
Don't you wait for me?
I'll
First
I'll just put that that pencil
What's the august september october no solo for rain. No, I want to
Oh
Maybe it was just like short notice
Or maybe she wasn't feeling good. Mm-hmm. It's a lot
Look at ivy just bow bobbing up and down she's like yelp yelp yelp yelp i'm ready
I love her jacket came comes up with her
And cheap bubbles
Oh
Yeah, we love we stand kingdom hearts in this home
This kingdom heart is good. I never had the opportunity. I thought the plan for october was giggle sticks
No, no, no, I had oh my god the script master got an absolute bulking and I got a refund on some stuff
Yeah, as you should I will I'm gonna rewrite it myself. I'm not even gonna lie to you
Well, apparently he might have already rewrote it. I've not looked at it, but I'm I'm I will I'm gonna take a peek right now
Yeah, I'll take a peek
He replaced giggle sticks with a light stick
Oh
Okay, I stopped meeting in the script now and it's just like fucking substitutes instead
Just rate cock
It's going on caterer. It's fine
Honestly
The fucking
Nuzzle punch
Awful
Oh, he literally just took out all of the direction
Oh
Is that actual script usable?
He left in cock-suckery
Cock-suckery
I mean if you can overlook that is a script usable question mark, we're not gonna have to go in
And I honestly I've been I have a bad taste in my mouth. Oh, we'll talk about this later. We'll talk about this later
Concert concert concert business business business business business
This is a great song too
My life stick burns brighter than ever
I got my life sticks here
Go off I mean
Don't forget to check out the link in the description guys because I've got all their links on youtube
Like they have worked so hard on this concert even a cheeky sub and a like on the stream right now
I pinned it in my chat. Just give it a cheeky like let them know that I've fucking enjoyed this because this is
Like I know you could argue. Oh, they're only singing a three-minute song. No behind the scenes. Are you kidding me?
There's so much stuff
And all while they were streaming as well on the background
They would have had to have been streaming and then like the vocal practice the warm-up practice songs record get it sent to a mixer edits
like just
Be good to them. Okay. Be good
Yes, yes, welcome to spam begets in the chat. Let them know the reefland showed up. Let me pick out such a long time
That's months of practice. You can see all the reeflands in the chat for getting good
You well, that's what I like to see you all get rewarded
Yeah, make sure to um click on the link in my chat give them a give them a like
Go check them out. Also up to the girls. I have very stuff in my description and all the other girls do too. So
Wait, is mercy in here? Or is she? No, mercy's not here. Mercy's by her lonesome. Okay
She said she would yep too much also us. Yeah, because she's like I'm gonna be real. I'm gonna be mad annoying
She's probably like also geeking out right now. It's probably it's like yapping a bunch
Oh my sweet mercy
Oh
I'm just gonna pretend that rain was like just tearing up on the guitar
Shrouding, can you play any instruments? Uh, no, I never learned I was athletic
Hmm
Um, I was called athletics and swimming as well
I'm running like athletics and the hardle athletics and I can just do their grippers
I'm not being the grippers. I like someone commented on my feet
They were like you have very long toes and I'm like, sorry you stuffed your toes so much that they're like fucking nubs
Like
If you didn't know you're supposed to be able to walk on them not like a little stubbly fucking
She took that
Harmony is the melody of the heart
I
Can't stop sharing it rains boobs
It's when she bounces we bounce so like
Yeah, they're like in and out
Oh
Oh my god another trio that's so impressive it's so impressive
He's got the lungs for this. I'm I'm tired just thinking and concept
Oh don't hurt him now don't hurt him
I also have long toes
You can really grip it with those long toes
Grip what
I
Group songs are much harder to mix together too. Oh
I mean, I feel like it's not hard to mix anything when it comes to these girls because they just naturally sound perfect
Yeah
They're singing voices. Yeah
Stoney can clap real good
Grip in the grippy stick with my grippers
Okay
I want that as a tramp stamp on my model
Hmm
I wonder what mic she uses raya because her stuff is so clear. I know it is for the gifted boy
Who that boy who him is I'm not saying okay, tyler go off
No, I'm too pasty to see that song
Are you enjoying it Zara? I just heard her giggle
That's the
Imagine this in 3d. Oh, that would be so good. I'll be pissing myself same
I even know how 3d concerts work
Oh
Yeah
He didn't say their knowledge. Come on lads. Come on refland's pill or break one
No, do the word go on refland's go on
There's this company and that helped
Utano Pandora to do her 3d concert. Um, and it's an upcoming company and I was like
Oh my god insider knowledge too. I met Utano Pandora before she debuted and before I debuted
That's so cool. Yeah, it's so cool. I mean she doesn't know that
She doesn't know that we met before but I know that we met before
Oh my god
She was so nice to me. I was um, she's so lovely, but I don't like interact with her anymore because she doesn't know who I am
Smile um
She's so so lovely
grin
Yeah, and her goal was to have a 3d concert and she achieved it. Oh, she achieved that's so sweet. We love girlies
Achieved achieved
Achieve those goals, uh, you're only holding yourself back
I
Look at Rayo bobble
I love seeing how like they move their models
It's not ogre yet
No, I'm core. Come on. Get the fuck get back on the stage god aim. We can finish it. Oh an idle song
We're melons and
We can funk together
Is that a is that a zora? Is that a zira?
Can you hear his face?
Are you saying it?
Are you having fun is your uh
Yeah
Oh
I didn't realize how reactive uh mimosas ears are yeah, they are they're all well rid
And her boobs too, I know I can't stop staring everyone's boobs
I
Don't sit in comparison there. I have like really bad eyes though. So sometimes mimosas arms look like a part of her hair
Yeah, little nuggie
Her arms are very thin so they tend to kind of disappear into her hair for sure
She's she's our little nugget
My little nugget now I want chicken nuggets
Oh my god, I had really good chicken nuggets yesterday. I know this is completely off topic. It's fucking delicious. I was like
I have bad eyes. It's not an excuse to stare boobs. Let me alone
Oh get it get it get it get it. This is so hate
Oh
Damn mimosas voice
Dinner her mouth tracking is really good
Hmm
Nothing wrong with wanting some strawberry milk get out of here
My
Question is are they doing a five-man song at the end? I bet I've hoped that you yeah
I wonder if they'll do like an original song
Yeah, that would be crazy
Some people do an original song. Yeah, why did we learn not do an original song?
Oh, I brought this stressful and I was trying to debut last thing I want to do is give them a custom song that like
To try and do but if you guys want a group we should all have an original we should have an a group song
Okay, I'll do the male part of the song
I'll do the rap part of the song
I'll do the backup vocals
That leaves us her mercy and I see
Perfect. We're good. Yeah, they can carry us through the through the actual vocals
exactly
I'll just do that. Yeah
Oh
Mommy right now taking notes honestly, bro. I'm spamming their dms. I'm like, how long did that fucking take?
We maybe even months honestly, maybe this has been cooking since day one. You never know
I know I want to ask the girls after
I
Want to eat the strawberries on her head. I want to eat her
Same. Well, look at the little saucy wink. She ended on she was like
She knows what she's doing. She knows it not to not to make you guys jealous, but
Please five man five man song come on
Mm-hmm
Moving on I know I just got scared. I'm like what's happening
Oh, I feel that
Oh
My god, I mean
Really big
Oh
What song is this
Original question. Is this a k-pop song? Is it capable? Yeah
What song is this I'm wondering
It makes sense that they picked like a yeah, that's true because they all have like girl singers different parts
It's a twice song. It is a twice song
I feel like I would recognize it if it was a twice song, but I guess I'm a fake twice fan
I
Name this particular member's grandmother's maiden name right now
Well, I'm getting tangles this is awesome. Oh my god
Can someone tell me what song this is
It's cda apparently. Okay, that makes more sense
Oh, it's kda. It's kda. Yeah. I had to somebody say it was twice. Why are you lying?
Oh, it's I'll show you by kda and twice. Okay. Oh, okay. Okay
Song for lead to league of legends. Oh, well, that's a zurra fucking happy
She's probably geeking out right now. Although I want to go to her stream
Allowing to she's gonna be saying all the words
We'll listen to a zero singing too. Yeah
She's probably harmonizing with them
Mm-hmm
Oh, she's not singing sing for me for me is there a sing
She's just bopping
Yeah
Wow, I'm almost as voice
I wish I could sing like that my god, I know me too. I wish I could sing in korean and in japanese
This sounds so good. This is such a great song for all of them
I
This has been must have been a lot of practice my god
I like how his ears is like in the corner
That chair
I
Her voice
No on core give us more
And one more
No
It cannot be on core you do like the dj scratch
Be like, oh last song. Yeah, you don't have to play even then dj scratch and they're all like, let's go
After party yeah
On reya's channel, yeah
I was really good
That was insane. Yeah, dang. Let's see arm
Give me one
I'm gonna see if we can either watch it. If no, I will redirect into her
I want to redirect into her
How do you redirect without ending stream?
Uh
Edit video
Yeah, but how do you send them? How do you send your viewers like to the stream without ending your own stream?
Can you not oh, I thought I didn't know what you were asking. No, I don't think
You could just probably just post a link and be like go